certaines m'irait bien vous voir vous
présenter à la prochaine élection
présidentielle où l'on vaut crédite de
20% des intentions de vote c'est
d'ailleurs assez amusant de voir chaque
journaliste qui vous interviewe pendre
un air inspiré pour vous faire remarquer
que votre livre semble un programme
politique et vous demander dans la
foulée si vous avez l'intention de vous
présenter en 2022
n'étant pas aussi bon comédien je vous
épargnerai ce petit numéro
ce ne sera pas la question que je vous
poserai ça dépend évidemment pas de vous
mais des sondages
il est donc bien trop tôt pour le dire
vous êtes d'accord on évacue cette
question merci de me faire ce plaisir
d'évacuer cette question mais ça dépend
pas que des sondages ça dépend aussi un
peu de moi et c'est pas du tout mon
intention c'est pas pour ça que j'ai
écrit ce livre n'ont sans doute pas mais
mais alberto si demain les sondages
disaient 45% des français veulent vous
présentiez vous sentiriez obligé de vous
présenter et ici en axant % ne vous
sentirez plus obligés du tout vous êtes
d'accord que ça va ça va jouer quand
même oui bien sûr mais c'est pas du tout
à l'ordre du jour c'est pas le sujet et
j'ai pas du tout l'intention de me
présenter aux présidentielles 2022
[Musique]